UNITED STATES SENATE.
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF HOW
BADLY THEY WANT TO DEAL OR
WHETHER THIS BECOMES A 2018
MIDTERM ELECTION, BRET.
>> Bret: THINGS IN THE WEST WING
WERE 50 TIMES WHAT YOU'VE HEARD,
AND HIS FORMER CHIEF STRATEGIST
IS STILL NOT TELLING LAWMAKERS
WHAT THEY WANT TO HEAR, BUT HE
IS TALKING TO SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
HAS NEW DETAILS ON THAT TONIGHT.
KATHERINE?
>> Reporter: A SOURCE CLOSE TO
THE MATTER CONFIRMS TO FOX NEWS
THE FORMER CHIEF STRATEGIST WAS
INTERVIEWED BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL THIS WEEK.
HE TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
THEY VOICED FRUSTRATION AFTER
BANNON INVOKED SPECIAL PRIVILEGE
ON BEHALF OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THERE WERE 25 QUESTIONS THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE AUTHORIZED HIM
TO ANSWER.
HE ANSWERED EACH OF THOSE.
HE WOULD NOT GO BEYOND THOSE
QUESTIONS IN ANY OF HIS ANSWERS.
AND THAT'S FRUSTRATING TO THOSE
OF US ON THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE FURTHER STEPS TO TAKE
AND WE'LL BE TAKING THOSE.
>> Reporter: FOX NEWS CONFIRMS
LATE LAST NIGHT, DON McGANN
EXPLAINED WHY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE COVERS THE TRANSITION.
THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH FOR THE
COMMITTEE'S RANKING DEMOCRAT WHO
CLAIMS BANNON'S IN CONTEMPT AND
HIS PRIVILEGE CLAIM IS OVERLY
BROAD AND UNSUSTAINABLE.
>> WE CANNOT PERMIT A SITUATION
WHERE THE WHITE HOUSE IS ALLOWED
TO SCRIPT SELF-SERVING AND
MISLEADING QUESTIONS.
>> Reporter: THE DEMOCRATS' MEMO
ABOUT THE ABUSES AND WHEN IT
WILL BE PUBLIC, THE CONGRESSMAN
HAD NO COMMENT AS HE WALKED AWAY
FROM REPORTERS, BRET.
>> Bret: KATHERINE, WHAT ARE WE
LEARNING FROM THE NEW INTERVIEW
FROM THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF?
>> Reporter: IN THE WIDE-RANGING
INTERVIEW, REINCE PRIEBUS SAID
THEY'RE AFRAID OF NO ONE, AND
THE BEHIND THE SCENES DRAMA,
QUOTE, TAKE EVERYTHING YOU'VE
HEARD AND MULTIPLY IT BY 50.
PRIEBUS SAID COMEY SAID HE KNEW
IT WOULD BE A POLITICAL MISTAKE.
BANNON APPARENTLY EXPLODED WITH
ANGER, QUOTE, "THERE'S NOT AN
F'ing THING YOU CAN DO TO SELL
THIS, HE SHOUTED, NOBODY CAN
SELL THIS, P.T. BARNUM COULDN'T
SELL THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DRESSED DOWN
JEFF SESSIONS, BLAMING HIS
RECUSAL FOR THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
APPOINTMENT.
PRIEBUS DESCRIBES A DRAMATIC
CHAIN OF EVENTS WHERE HE RAN
DOWN TO THE WEST WING PARKING
LOT, GOT IN SESSIONS' BLACK
SEDAN AND URGED HIM NOT TO QUIT.
I DRAGGED HIM BACK UP TO MY
OFFICE FROM THE CAR.
MIKE PENCE AND BANNON CAME IN
AND WE STARTED TALKING TO HIM TO
THE POINT HE DECIDED HE WOULD
NOT RESIGN RIGHT THEN.